Let's start off with the domain. Our lowest x coordinate of any point on the
green curve is over here at negative 8. And we can see that this dot is filled
in, so we need an inclusive bracket there. The highest in x that we'd move is
over here but we have an open circle at x equals 9. Since we write a 9, but we
write an open bracket to show that 9 is not included. So, now for the range.
Let's look at the graph from this direction, then. The smallest value for f of x
for any of the given inputs that are possible, in this function is -3, and that
point is not included because of the open circle. The highest value for y is at
y equals 9. So our range, then, goes from -3 to 9, not including negative 3, but
including 9.